was on the field of
ANM where many the
solders what you're about to see is an
actual video clip of Civil War veterans
in 1938 telling War Stories this was
filmed at the Gettysburg reunion
commemorating the 75th anniversary of
that famous battle the average age of
the veterans who attended was 94 years
old the government had begun planning
this event four years prior and in the
initial stages of planning the first
major challenge was to find out how many
Civil War veterans were still alive and
to contact all of them by 1936 they
found that there were 12,500 soldiers
still alive and by the time the event
occurred in 1938 only 8,000 remained and
from that close to 1,900 of them showed
up to the event 25 of whom actually
fought in the Battle of Gettysburg
itself
this will be the last Civil War reunion
for both Confederate and Union Soldiers
to meet
together so now let us hear from the
soldiers themselves for in their voices
and words hold the weight of memories of
comrades lost of Victories won and of
the unyielding spirit that propelled
them forward through those uncertain
times in history we had a band at our
country by the name of B he was a great
hand to go out and for so he in one day
with a chicken and the man where he the
man that he took the chicken from come
in and reported it and now he says
bed the captain says bed you were under
rest for 3 Days Sergeant take it to the
guard house so we took him to the guard
house and put him upstairs that's only
guard house that we had at that time and
the second day he was in there when he
got his feet he crumbled his heart back
down got dropped dropped a loop down and
pretty soon the pigs come around and you
know they
uh loop he stepped in the loop and the
pigs went to climbing right up the side
of the house and come in and the man
come down he says oh my lieutenant let
that man out he's now stealing my pigs
so they let him
out H
H we had a bad in the service and he was
he was picking those things off of his
pants you know and they come along and
say uh those arithmetic bugs that we
have
now what do you call
rithmetic back the reason why you call
them arithmetic bugs is this they add to
my by uh they add to my discomfort they
subtract from my pleasure and they M
toly like
H off of the day came along and he saw a
Mike have taken the graybacks out of the
seams of his pants so he says Mike I see
you're picking them out no Jaber says
mik I'm Mike I'm taking them as I they
come
and on down High way and I'll be
searching in any place I and when I find
it that one good highway I'll be
thinking this is the way to
[Music]
go
[Applause]
[Music]